qui d'autre que l'AFP emploie 50
journalistes textes photos vidéos à
Jérusalem Gaza et ramala qui d'autre
parvenait encore jusqu'à samedi à
envoyer seul des images de
gazaville qui d'autre a diffusé depuis
le 7 octobre 242 reportages je ne parle
pas de simple factuel mais de vraies
histoires construite dont 96 depuis
Israël 53 depuis Gaza et les territoires
occupé qui d'autre pour ne prendre que
quelques reportages de ce matin a
raconté l'histoire de ces jeunes d'un
kibou se ravager qui retournent à
l'école après les enterrements ou
interview le créateur de la série Foda
expliquant pourquoi la guerre à Gaza
avait dépassé tous les
scénarios Maurice Levy a écrit une très
belle tribune intitulé jamais depuis la
Choa la communauté juive de France ne
s'était sentie aussi isolée évoquant les
40 Français juifs assassiné le 7 il
écrit qui étaient ces 40 français quelle
était leur vie étaient-ils parents on ne
sait rien d'eux parce que l'on ne veut
rien savoir ni leur nom ni leurs âges ni
leur vie ni leur visag lafp a commencé
de raconter la vie de certaines de ses
victimes grâce à son réseau de
journalistes en contact régulier avec
des familles d'otage et de la presse
israélienne
elle est parvenue hier
a identifié 208 des 239 otages recensés
par les autorités
elle a décompté au moins 34 enfant dont
17 de moins de 10 ans l'otage le plus
jeune est un nourrisson âgé de 9 mois
enlevé dans le kibut nirose avec son
frère Ariel 4 ans et ses parents de
jeunes trentenair octogénaires figurent
parmi les
captifs qui d'autre que laafp a fait ce
travail